though 2018 Halloween recaptures the
stripped-down aesthetics of carpenters
original vision there's still a handful
of treats scattered among its tricks
waiting to be found by sharp eyed fans
come along with us as we give you a
brief rundown of the secrets hiding in
Halloween shadows just watch out for the
boogeyman and spoilers understandably
the focus of much of Halloween type has
been on Jamie Lee Curtis and the return
of the role that made her famous Laurie
Strode curtis's 1978 performance remains
iconic in the annals of horror history
earning her the lingering title of
scream queen she played Laurie again
across three other decades starring in
1981 s Halloween to 1998 Halloween h2o
and 2002 s Halloween resurrection
she even lent her voice to Halloween 3
season of the witch the unrelated
standalone entry in which she can be
heard as an announcer however while
those previous sequels tended to leave
Laurie sidelined in a hospital bed or
killed off after a glorified cameo the
2018 film is fully dedicated to her
story exploring the trauma that has
affected her life and her family
less obvious are some other returning
performers joining Curtis Michael Myers
is played by two different actors in
carpenters film
Nick Castle was the man behind the mask
while tony moran portrayed the killer
for the single scene in which his face
can be glimpsed castle is back this time
around sharing the role of Michael with
newcomer James Jude Courtney the new
Halloween takes us back to the fictional
town of Haddonfield Illinois the small
community once rocked by Michael Myers
as original murders while the story
keeps a tight focus on Laurie her
daughter Karen and her granddaughter
Allison the filmmakers nonetheless made
sure to include a few nods to the
continuing history of the town around
them the original Halloween was shot
during the summer in California
grappling with a very modest budget
carpenter's crew had to simulate a
Midwestern autumn by spreading dead
leaves on the ground
despite the trees visibly blooming in
several shots the new movie shot in
South Carolina in the winter recreates
this unsettling juxtaposition during an
early scene in which Alison and her
friends stroll down Hatton fields leaf
strewn sidewalks under green foliage
beyond the visuals citizens are
name-checked to with Alison's boyfriend
Cameron Elam established as the son of
Lonnie Elam a troublemaking classmate of
young Tommy Doyle
in 1978 in addition to set dressing and
name drops Stephen Gordon green and
Danny McBride peppered their new
Halloween with a number of cinematic
allusions to its predecessor from in
jokes and references to inversions and
reversals it will be impossible for
longtime Halloween fans to watch this
new take without feeling a certain sense
of deja vu this is obvious right from
the opening titles which revived the
jack-o'-lantern that kicked off the
first movie Michaels 2018 hospital
Escape mirror says first with white gown
mental patients wandering eerily by the
glow of car headlights later a familiar
playground rhyme echoes during the
trick-or-treat sequence the real fun
begins though when laurie herself takes
the place of michael in a number of
familiar moments particularly the
climactic balcony fall and subsequent
disappearance her face also looms in the
darkness behind him at one point just as
he had loomed behind her in the end the
fire that at last consumes the shape
also burns a dollhouse which bears a
passing resemblance to the original
Myers home while the new movie ignores
all the sequels that preceded it McBride
and Greene still set out with an
intention to pay tribute to every
Halloween movie their film states that
Michael has been in custody
ever since that fateful night in 1978
making it clear that none of his later
shenanigans ever happened in its world
however winks and nods abound to consult
fans who might be miffed about this new
timeline 1981 s Halloween 2 revealed
that Laurie and Michael were siblings
suggesting that his killing spree was
somehow motivated by his own bloodline
further sequels took this concept
further sending the shape after more
relatives and proposing an ancient curse
as his motivation the new movie has
Allison quickly dispelled the notion of
Laurie and Michael being sister and
brother wasn't it her brother converted
all those babies interesting yeah it was
not her brother that's the main and
people made up more subtle sequel
references include a glimpse at
Halloween three sinister masks a gas
station bearing a strong resemblance to
a set from the return of Michael Myers
and a public restroom setting similar to
a scene in h2o
Donald Pleasance was one of the few
consistent mainstays of the Halloween
sequels playing dr. Sam Loomis and five
films before his death acting as
something of a van Helsing to Michael's
Dracula Loomis dedicated his entire life
to stopping his famous patient even when
no
believed him about the danger they were
in in the first movie he sums up the
sheep's unknowable motivations as
succinctly as possible I realized that
what was living behind that boy's eyes
was purely and simply evil the new movie
pays rather subtle but brilliant homage
to this idea though the 2018 Halloween
takes place in a timeline where Michael
never escaped again during the late
Loomis's lifetime
his dedication still plays a major role
and the character even makes a cassette
tape cameo via a pleasant sound alight
we are introduced to a man dubbed the
new Loomis by lorry doctor Sartain whose
unhealthy obsession with understanding
Michael's motivations leads him to
betray the heroes towards the film's
climax in the end the bad doctor learns
that what Laurie and Loomis have always
said is true there's no reasoning with
pure evil as a matter of fact it was